normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government in an
email released from the house oversight
committee on Wednesday a bank secrecy
act manager raised concerns the payments
did not appear to correspond to any
services rendered as well as Chinese
efforts to Target uh children of
politicians the investigator suggested
the bank re-evaluate its relationship
with the client so you had private
sector concerns that homeboy over here
was taking dirty money from foreign
governments well here we are ladies and
gentlemen with new UFO news breaking uh
uh as we speak how about that I want to
I want to I want to explain something to
everybody how uh how money in finance
works you know they talk about Donald
Trump hiring his family and his kids and
all that stuff and I'm like yeah it's
not an easy thing to do if you own a
business and let's say let's say you own
a car dealership you're pulling a
million bucks a month that's like a good
amount for a car dealership now not
saying profit that's your revenue and so
you got some you got a good let's say
you got a good profit margin you think
I'm going to hire my son done and I'm
going to pay him six figures good luck
you need a clearly defined job a job
title a legitimate job title A
recognizable job title with clearly
defined hours and structure because
what's going to happen is government's
going to come for you and say what does
your son do why are you giving your son
this salary we have questions why let's
say you as an individual make a million
bucks a year you're in the highest tax
bracket possible so you're giving like
half of your paycheck to the government
let's say you get a paycheck for $10,000
cut that in half give the government
5,000 that's how it works let's say you
decide to hire your son and pay him
5,000 bucks a month well now you've cut
your cash in half for your $5,000 you're
still cutting that in half now the
government's only getting 25 your son
who only makes a 100 is in a lower tax
bracket now the government's not getting
at 5,000 they thought every month
they're getting only like 35 or four
this is why you cannot just give money
to your family and your kids unless you
have outlined clearly in the documents
in your corporate paperwork and all of
that stuff it is not I I don't act like
it's a difficult thing I'm just saying
if there's no clear services rendered it
is not surprising that the the bank
staff guy was like uh we should
re-evaluate working with this guy cuz
that clearly is going to put them in
like this bank is probably like we're
going to get we're going to they're
going to file discovery on us we're
going to get investigated this guy's
clearly got illegitimate dealings going
on we can clearly see it so he's
required to to look for that federal law
there's all sort this this huge thing
and and this is exactly why so it's it's
it is not so easy in business just to
have money and give money away first of
all you can't give money away there's
limits there's tax there's there's gift
limits per year plus lifetime gift
limits if you fire if you if you hire
family members and they don't have
clearly defined titles that are
recognizable and they're not being paid
a market competitive salary they are
going to come after you it's it's wild I
I'm I you know look you start you start
a business and all of a sudden you're a
republican that's that's what they say
right and the reason why these Democrats
don't understand they think it's because
of taxes I'm like it's not just that
it's like you might want to pay someone
a premium and now you've got to argue
why you're paying someone a premium oh
this guy's really really good at his job
he should get paid more and then they're
like you're paying him 40% above Market
why we want to know why that money is
going to him and not to us and you that
that's the kind of stuff they could go
after you whenever they feel like it
like I don't want to do the whole you
know conservative imagine if the shoe
was on the other foot thing but I I
should point out that Donald Trump is
currently on trial for fraud in New York
state oh yeah and none of the banks
filed any reports like this whatsoever
no they're defending him yeah didn't
just out this was normal they've all in
fact it's been the exact opposite and
they defended back because they paid
back with with you know with profit and
that's why the banks were willing to
continue to do this um and yet we have
another situation here where the banks
were raising red flags were filing
potential fraud reports and nothing
seems to happen well they're not
supposed to be mad about the bidens
you're only supposed to be mad about the
trumps the bidens are this is the three
tier system of justice right and I heard
you quote this the other day um that
it's it's it's the three tiers and I
keep saying this over and over so it
used to be two now it's three right so
tier one that is like that's the elites
that's that's Hillary that's if you're
last name is Obama Clinton uh Biden
Epstein at one point um you know you are
fine right well until you're a loose end
like like chovin uh for example he's a
loose end so you know got to get rid of
him so well he was never in their Club
that's no no no no no but I just mean
Loose Ends um that that you know that's
tier one you'll you can do whatever you
want for the most part um then tier two
so tier two this is like this is like
normal you know you get pulled over for
speeding that kind of thing that your
Normy kind of law that's your normal
stuff and then tier three is Trump and
Trump supporters and Trump and Trump
supporters have a whole extra set of
laws
that you know you know okay maybe you
were just walking through the capital on
your way out of the capital that means
you get beat over you get beat beat in
the back with a baton by the police even
as you're complying with their orders or
how about your your a married couple who
shows up an hour and a half after people
have already were already leaving you
have no idea what's going on there's no
signs there's no cops there's no
barriers you walk up and look around and
then leave and they accuse you of all of
the same crimes and sentence you to a
year in jail that happened I met I met
some of these people I met them at a
restaurant and they said hour and a half
after people that already left and all
that was done they walk up and there's
the building door is open no barricades
no signs nothing there's no they're not
anywhere near any of the fighting or
broken glass and they walk up and
they're looking around and they wave and
they say okay whatever and then they
leave and then next thing they know six
seven months later they're getting
served uh for for criminal charges for
having just walked around in DC shout
out to Owen Troyer who is currently
Behind Bars who didn't even go into the
capital and was at a permitted rally mhm
but doesn't matter but they just brought
up all of his post this is what they're
saying you think the wrong thing you say
the wrong thing you're in trouble and we
want we want you to be behind bars but
but but I want to stress in the three
tiers of Justice a slight correction the
first tier is as you described but the
second tier is you own a bodega and a
guy comes in and smashes everything and
the cops don't show up for any reason so
that means you're in this no 's land the
laws aren't enforced against you and
they won't be enforced for you then you
have the bottom tier of being the Trump
trump supporters and the Maga people
where you're not getting you could be
swatted 15 times in a year ain't nobody
going to help you and you fart in public
and they're going to lock you up yes
this is this is sort so in the Russian
Civil War During the buwi Revolution
when the bus first got in power um the
idea was in Libya we were chatting on
this uh before we got here and if you
read Always With Honor by uh PTO Rangel
who was the General that fought against
the communist actually got to visit his
grave in Belgrade a couple weeks ago
just amazing this right it's right in
this little Al Cove in a church and it's
not marked or anything before you go
into the church but everybody knows that
it's that's that's General Rangel and
his his estate has completely refused
even now after the fall of the Soviet
Union to have it his body uh transferred
back to Russia because that's where he
wanted to go because that um that church
specifically is dedicated to the Russian
imperial family the romanovs oh wow and
that's that's from his perspective he
was fighting for the rightful rulers of
the country and as a as a patriot and so
he said in this Memoir that at one point
that if you were a a criminal who was
caught with a knife well the criminal
doesn't know any better he's responding
to socio-economic factors that are out
of his control it's not his fault that
he's lashing out this way Society has
has wronged him we you know we must take
care of him we must uh help him and put
him back on the street but if you get
caught with a knife if you get caught
with one even if you haven't used it yet
now you're a criminal now you're a
domestic terrorist and you must be
treated as An Enemy of the State so 100
years ago in Russia this is exactly what
they were doing yeah and also because
I've been looking at the gulag
archipelago which I know a lot of people
have been talking about lately but um
Soulja nson talks about when he was in
prison at the lubianka uh which I don't
know how you spell that but whatever
when how when he was in prison and he
was being interrogated and everything
spell in Russian by the way spell it in
Russian yeah I would I would never do
that right um but he talked about how
people would come in and they would be
interrogated and they would mention a
former colleague who maybe they had been
friendly with and then the next thing
they know that former colleague is
getting Dragged In and being
interrogated and it's just this
Perpetual guilt by association even
though there hasn't been any guilt at
any point you know Soldier nson was
dragged in um while he was serving in
the military and he was dragged in for
you know crimes and it turned out that
his biggest crime was that he had an old
friend who was on the front lines of the
opposing side and they were sending each
other letters they were like still
friendly he was commun with the Enemy
right do you think awareness of the
multi-tier justice system uh is strong
enough to affect how people are going to
vote like do you think that people who
are on the fence have seen what's
happened to the people involved in
January 6th and will say January do
think it's not January 6 it's that a a
bodega worker had his got stabbed or
there trying to kill him and he stabbed
a guy and they lock him up that there
was a family this this was a big story
looters came in and just destroyed
everything for no reason and the
family's life and savings were wiped out
they're they they lost 20 grand in
product regular people are experiencing
that in Arco tyranny yeah or like when
you go to the store and you can't buy
anything without searching around for
someone to unlock a cabinet and there's
nobody working and it's just a self
checkout everyone's just getting high in
the back my favorite is in Chicago the
Walgreens where there's no products it's
just little signs you no it's uh no no
no you it's an big empty room with a
with a terminal and you walk up and type
in what you want and then after you pay
someone will walk out and carry the
product to you interesting yeah crazy
you know that's sort of like how grocery
stores used to be my great-grandfather
had a grocery store in Brooklyn and it
would be like he would be behind the
counter and my great-grandmother and
people would come in and say what they
wanted and they would bring them the the
the stuff you know what that is that's
ra that's a form of rationing yeah
that's actually a form of rationing it's
not just against shoplifting that's if
Soviet Union that you know Tanya Tay
will tell me that she remembers um not
from when she was like a little older
but when she was younger that if you
wanted to go to the store that you had
to get your ration stamps and then you
went to the store and you waited in line
and you waited and you waited and you
waited and you kept waiting and then
eventually if you had a you know the
specific stamp for as you say the item
that you were looking for then you
handed it to the part to the worker then
they would go into the back then they
would get it then they would bring it
out because people don't understand that
in in Eastern Europe in Russia and
Belarus Ukraine after the fall of the
Soviet Union it was a complete Wild Wild
West freefor all for almost a complete
decade and crime and and like actual
Highway robbers like we say highway
robbery but like actual Highway Bandits
that was a huge thing you would get some
of that stuff and some people would
would you know gang up on you right on
the outside so you had to go in in uh
you know member so when Society
collapses and you are inside of it um
all sorts of horrible things happen I
remember covering the Freddy gray riots
and it was like everybody knew everybody
knew that at a certain time like it's
all just going to go have you ever uh
had the Eastern European wafer cake
which kind oh oh like the like the full
cake the layers so it's it's wafer yeah
all the time sweet condensed milk layer
sweet condensed milk and uh when I was
in Ukraine they told me well what
happened was they had didn't they had no
flower you have you have nothing so what
do you do when your guests are going to
come over you boil in condensed milk and
then you put a thin wafer you pour some
on it you put another wafer on top you
pour another layer and that's how you
make a cake to have but it's literally
just condensed milk yeah Tanya's T's mom
makes that for like special occasions
it's really good like it's like all
sugar but it's interesting it's like
something for special occasions that was
an adaptation to the times that they
were in right I mean I think about how
many Kissinger died yeah it just it just
passed in the chat here so really he
didn't pass in the chat but they just
mentioned it so he was in our chat when
he di
sorry thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 pm
and become a member over at timcast.net